[Music]
welcome to between two ponds today with
us is Grandmaster Dennis burrows Dennis
welcome so tell us a little bit about
yourself where are you from I'm from
Hungary
we're from Hungary in Budapest oh who
passed on ice okay obviously not from
whorl hungry well part of my family
isn't from the rural side but I was born
in Budapest
what's the chess culture like there oh
it's a big chess culture there like
hungry was the first nation to actually
defeat the Soviets oh really
actually maybe not well in 1978 we
defeated the Soviets nice and became the
Olympic champion and so did you grow up
there yes and what did you move here I
moved here in around 2010 to go to
school yes at Texas Tech and then
Webster kata-kata and what's your degree
in psychology
aha psychology so maybe later we talk a
little bit the psychology of chess but
right now since it's topical what are
your thoughts on the World Championship
just ended well it was very exciting and
I felt that Caruana was very close to
becoming the world champion but what I
found also very interesting that cause
he used the same road map in this rapid
championship than in the previous
tiebreak wouldn't I roadmap meaning he
had a plan the pre plan for this
tiebreaker and if you put together the
last games both of them the last game of
cause I'm playing Caruana
in the last round and Kuryakin playing
black against Costin you'll see he plays
the Marat see interesting and he always
does that in the last round but the
reason is probably because he wanted to
have a solid position and it did work
out well in both games so there's been a
lot of talk about the you know the type
rakes and the classical and what what
are your thoughts on what would you
change if you were gonna organize her I
would definitely reverse the order I
know this was mentioned more by many
good players like mo suit offski Kramnik
and I totally agree with it because I
think chess should be celebrated
by winning a classical championship and
not the rapid part why do they even
include rapid and lifts it seems like an
odd thing to include it's not like you
play the World Series and then you play
nine innings and then you're if you're
tied that you would switch to a
different version or a different game
why do you think they include that at
all
yeah I think that's also that's kind of
weird but yeah even in tennis they
decide early on who will have the
advantage and they don't make a big deal
of it they just have a coin flip
everybody's fine with that and so I
think even for chess it would be fine to
have rapid as decider who gets the
drawers and just have it decided in the
classical right right interesting good
so what do you anticipate for the next
championship do you feel like there will
be actually be any changes or do you
feel like it'll be the same it really
depends on the organizers and how this
just chess community feels about it
right I don't know if it also depends
where the championship will be held will
it be st. Louis or no way I don't know
time will tell time goes up yeah so okay
let's let's talk a little bit by
yourself then sir favourite chess memory
of your chess playing mmm actually one
of my favorite chess memory is connected
to get Caruana and he was living in
Spain and then he moved to Budapest okay
I played had many times when we were
little right I did beat him first time I
was 14 I was 11 but later on we played
again and the result wasn't as fun for
me but what was the exciting is that I
was browsing through the candidates
games and it was last round and previous
candidates when karyakin qualified and
actually what I found is that Fabi is
playing the opening that I played him in
the last game we played
that's all I played there Easter rouser
and guess how Kuryakin responded the
same way as Fabi responded to my flats
money richer I was like
shock what's going on right what is this
that is awesome so when did you become a
Grand Master what year I became a Grand
Master at age 21 I'm not sure about the
year I am mildly now I'm 30 okay so how
just you know how describe like the road
to becoming like a master yes how was
that for you though I'll be honest it's
a tough frustrating road in the
beginning and my thoughts at that moment
was why can't I have such a fun game
that I see on other boards why are all
of my games so boring but okay that time
I learned more and gradually I overcame
this obstacle but it's it does take a
lot of time to get used to it what is
this thick time okay yeah
so who's the highest rated player you'd
be Lazaro besides Bobby when you were 11
Lazaro bruising got it he was twenty six
seventy buddy was twenty seven hundred
in his height okay cool so what would
you be doing if you weren't playing
chess that's a good question probably
radio like broadcaster broadcaster shock
jock because my dad is actually a
comedian oh really / musician do you
have any jokes prepared you could tell I
don't have choked speak there that I
only just joke when I feel I do improv
more than that so what's you what did
you want to be when you were a kid did
you always I never never thought about
it too actively I always was drawn to
chest really what do you attribute that
to my brother my brother was one of the
best juniors in hungry Indy know else
80s and he had chances to qualify and he
came third in the Hungarian championship
in the junior section but he became a
lawyer instead but he always had a huge
love for the game right and he showed me
lots of lots of books
Kasparov and the pole guards so I knew a
lot about these great players even
before I started speaking of those two
do you still get like starstruck around
them especially in st. Louis I mean all
these people are here do you get like
that are you comfortable with them yet
or is it still you know yes so I mean
with some I got comfortable with but to
be honest when I meet
Judit Polgar always get starts yeah yeah
that's awesome well even with Gary to
like he's just as intense casually in
one-on-one than he is you know in front
of everybody else is interesting that is
disarming so yeah great to meet her
nice what's your favorite tournament to
watch in st. Louis I do love these close
tournaments yes yeah I do love watching
these close tournaments here and even
playing them because believe it or not
even compared to other close tournaments
it it has way more decisive results and
I love the mix of older GM's and young
up colleagues yes yes fighting each
other because for some reason there's no
love between and they play forever and
you get exciting games right huh so
another kind of off topic question what
what's your favorite game besides chess
um I really like board games I don't
know if it's called risk here in America
risk yeah yeah I loved risk it's an
amazing board game right and I used to
play that in my family and yeah you know
the consequence yes yes an interesting
theme that keeps coming up and all these
interviews and just talking a lot of
grandmasters is how much family was
important to their chess playing and
everybody it was the mom the dad the
brothers you know Lynette it is an
interesting theme that comes up I don't
know a lot of people that just kind of
came to chess on their own would you
hear that or do you think that's no no I
think that's a good observation I feel
that most of the people get close to
chess because of family and actually
they're telling like tales that my
great-great-grandfather was a good chess
player but I would never
to find of any documents about it right
right so what are you doing your free
time when you're not playing chess well
I watch a lot of movies and series
what's the last movie that you watched
the last movie I watched hmm I haven't I
don't remember what I watched last time
but I'm planning to watch the Freddie
Mercury Mikado humorously yes yes yes
God who are your top three bands my top
three bands I love Tom Petty and the
Heartbreakers
and obviously it's closely related
I love Traveling Wilburys right and it's
like plenty of musicians
and yeah I feel like that's the last
real supergroup I don't you don't think
that happens since then but anyway go
ahead yeah actually when you said
supergroup that reminded me of cream
right also amazing but I haven't heard
of cream is great yeah yeah Wow so what
else do you do besides you know that
kind of stuff do you you read a lot yeah
I read you usually eyebrows and surf the
internet about me and learning more
about what's going on in the world but
I'm always interested if there's new
biopic scumming up just like this
Freddie Mercury driving also I kind of
see and when I looked at Moloch playing
Freddie yeah I was amazed I can't decide
if it's is this an old photo or is it
actually Moloch that's funny you know I
supposed to play him was the guy that
Borat oh yeah yeah yeah yeah they would
have interesting Laura so shifting
topics again there back to your said you
got a psychology degree yeah does that
help with chess at all do you feel like
or what it would have looked concrete
things can you take from that education
to put into your chess game yeah
definitely it helps you to have a
psychological understanding of the game
and I think that was kind of a little
bit of a difference between cause and
Fabi and cause them car yakun because
cause then had it all laid out he knew
what he's going to do in the upcoming
four games and he was just following
that plan
and I felt that for example car yakin
was more guessing what he's supposed to
do while calls then just know okay now
I'm in the lead okay let's play steady
position right and what was very
exciting is he knew what he wants to do
and then he reached it like if you
remember the last game between cousin
and Caruana Khurana chose the c5 e six
Sicilian but cousins knowledge is so
West that he knew that there's a move
like c4 there which transposes into a
more closed Marazzi type of structure
and why I'm repeating this is that he
kind of molds his chest knowledge of its
psychological planning like this
cognitive maps he uses to get ready and
just to actually use this as a weapon
for a match and I think that's very
exciting so do you think there's enough
of that at the you think that's
important to know it like at the lower
levels of chess like obviously that's
you know high level they need those kind
of strategies and whatnot but but should
be people be integrating that now
they're playing the 1500s the 2000s I
think it's good if you follow a set of
plans because then you can improve let's
say for example I know that cause and
play the sveshnikov when he was much
younger now he returned to that and that
gave him extra experience because he's
been playing that since little childhood
right and it's the same for everybody
else
if you keep practicing one thing after a
while you'll be a master at that right
right so what what advice do you have
for people that that you don't see them
doing a lot like well it's like the calm
most common mistake you see with chess
players um not being open to the world I
think that's a big mistake because you
do learn a lot about human experience
even when I read and listened a lot to
Freddie Mercury I learned about the
world and how to live life right and how
not to live life so
it's very exciting to learn about other
people's experiences but you have to be
open for that so one of the what are
your ideas of a tournament that you
don't see a lot like what's the sort of
a format you'd like to see my idea is to
have a standing only tournament where
you cannot sit thoughts ah standing you
cannot I like the tournament where you
do the underwater game it's like you go
scuba diving make the move and rush up
just to hit the clock let's be currently
it's like a thirty Seconds game where
you get 10 seconds x-ray thank you for
joining us today if you guys have any
questions for him he's gonna be here for
a while let us know please comment in
the comment section if not thanks for
joining us
[Music]
you